[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka yolo swaggins in this
video we're breaking down lord of the
rings the rings of power the first two
episodes have just dropped on amazon
prime video and throughout this we'll be
talking about all the easter eggs in it
call backs or call forwards and what you
need to know about the characters and
locations now i think we'd be remiss for
not talking about house of the dragons
and the similarities to it both are
prequel stories set before the events of
the main series and they adapt elements
of the slightly less famous books to
tell a story that will likely set up
things for the main one i'm going to
check out these episodes earlier in the
week and i was asked how it compares to
the game of thrones prequel and i ended
up explaining it like this i feel that
both this and house of the dragons tie
into the things that they tie into and
they're comparable in the same way that
lord of the rings is to game of thrones
both deal with legends involving
mystical myths but it's the tone that
sets the two apart to be completely
honest my brain is kind of from trying
to hold every bit of law from both in it
but as long as i say sean bean once per
breakdown i think i should be all right
farewell to the happy memories of my
first date with my wife you're getting
replaced with a dwarves family tree now
the series will take elements from the
silmarillion which was a book written by
j.r.r tolkien that was then edited by
his son christopher and released after
his death it's divided up into five
parts with the first telling the
creation of aya which is another name
for the universe it's very much a
biblical parallel that follows a god
known as illavata who creates all that
is also pronunciation in this video it's
going to range from stuff like ilovata
elevator ilovator and just me just
genuinely getting most of this stuff
wrong anyway the book talks about him
making the earth which is called otter
and his children who'd gone to become
the elves and men the planet was odder
better faster stronger but it was
destroyed by the rebellious malkor
melkor was also known as morgoth and
he's a character whose name pops up at
several points in these opening episodes
now the silmarillion explains the name
change like it's a sort of voldemort
situation where the name melkor gets
associated with evil to the point that
the elves won't mention it and instead
they say morograth
morgarth now we learned that the men
were loyal to him and that they're now
paying the price with elves keeping them
all in check morgoth was basically
middle earth's answer to lucifer and
though he was initially created by god
to be a force for good over time he
turned against his master now this is
why the opening line of the series by
galadriel says nothing is evil in the
beginning and this show will likely have
her depicting how a constant quest for
vengeance can cause a lot of issues
eventually morgoth became the first dark
lord which then ushered in sauron sauron
in the book is described as always
walking behind him to the point that he
ends up very much becoming his shadow
now that's everything you need to know
about the first part of the book and the
second describes the supernatural powers
of ayer with the third chronicling the
events of the first age this includes
the war over the silmarils which popped
up in the second entry the fourth
section takes place in the second age
and this recounts the fall of numenor
the final segment is based around the
third age and the rings of power
unfortunately there's so much stuff to
cover that we won't be able to go in
depth on it here as i just want to stick
to the main things but i've got to give
a massive shout out to the youtube
channel nerd of the rings who put
together so much expansive material on
the series books and also films you'll
be glad real that you check them out and
also make sure you hit the like and sub
on these videos as we're covering the
series every week anyway we start off
with galadriel narrating the story to us
and this is of course riffing on the
opening of the fellowship of the rings
this introduction echoes the prologue of
that film and we have a big exposition
dump that's also filled with a major
battle galarial talks about how before
there was even a sunrise there was light
and your old science folks out there
might be wondering how this is well when
ilotto first created order he made it
completely flat eventually the world
would twist into a globe but in his age
it was lit by two trees of valinor these
were the golden ones which was called
laureline and the silver one which was
called halperian these were destroyed by
morgoth like what we see here and we
join a young galadriel making about that
she sails down a river eventually this
opens up into a swan but it's dumped
into the water by the other kids now
could potentially foreshadow how
galadriel jumps off the boat at the end
of this episode and there are a couple
of lines here and there that sort of set
this up this is through her brother
finrod who tells her the parallel about
why a stone sinks he states that because
it only sees downward into the darkness
of the riverbed that it's tempted by
this leading to it singing down to the
bottom again this could be a reach or it
might highlight how collateral's quest
for revenge ends up pulling her back
into the water and away from the silver
shorts he also tells her that the ship
sails because it looks up into the sky
at the light but she's confused over
which direction to go tying into her
very much wrestling with her overall
quest after the trees are destroyed the
land plunges into darkness and they all
sail from valinor lots of foreshadowing
to the end of the episode at this point
including the sea clouds that form on
the horizon and the birds that pop up at
the end you also see a giant serpent in
the sundering sea and one of these
attacks galadriel's rescue boat in the
second episode i'll talk about this more
when we get to that but the sea serpents
were referencing tolkien's work and he
referred to them as being fish dragons
now the elves traveled to middle earth
and we see the battle in all its glory
with our initial focus being on a hell
hawk this was the same type of creature
that the ring rates would later ride and
i'll talk about how we might be setting
up one of these later on now we see
buddies floating in a sea of red and i
believe that this montage encompasses
all of the war of wrath which marked the
end of the first age i also got a lot of
vibes of sauron's eye in the tower from
the red glow emanating off the ones in
the back it's possible that this is the
first kinsling which had fenal leading
his forces of elves to attack the
talaria elves in order to take their
ships we see elves floating in what
appears to be water with an elf spear
impaling an elf making me think that it
could be this now it was during the
second age that we saw the rise of
sauron and this is basically where all
the show will be taking place with a
lord of the rings being set in the third
age we had a lot of help on elf crime
the war lasted for centuries and it
completely rocked middle earth where
there being countless deaths which we
see demonstrated in the pile of helmets
whereas the elves originally never had a
word for death because of this conflict
they ended up gaining several orcs
spread throughout the land and it's at
this point that we're introduced to
sauron who like the books is morgoth's
most faithful follower now finrod in the
source material was searching for a
silmaril and he was captured by sauron
which led to an epic battle of song it
was basically like when they do a
sing-off on the voice and in the box he
was killed by wolves and sauron's
fortress when we cut to finrod's body we
can actually see claw marks in his arms
and i believe that this is tying back to
his fate now it's at this point that we
also see sauron symbol for the first
time and this pops up throughout even
the elves can't figure out what it means
and i've seen theories that it's a map
of mortal as well as it even being an
eye let me know below what you think but
galadriel vowed to take revenge on
sauron and she took her brother's two
tree daggers which he carries with her
at all times now let me know if i'm
reaching mate but i got a lot of vibes
of the aftermath of world war ii laced
throughout these two entries we have
symbols that carry connotations with
them and galadriel could be seen as a
metaphor for the nazi hunters trying to
track down agents of evil there's also
the land of men that used to work with
morgoth and after the war ended many
countries that were loyal to the germans
were looked over by the allies similar
to what the elves do here again i might
be drawing comparisons that aren't there
but as we're analyzing it i thought i'd
talk about how i perceived some of the
themes now galadriel and her group
literally hunt sauron to the ends of
middle earth and they scale giant
mountains in an attempt to try and track
him down it's clear the rest of the
company's heart's not in it anymore and
they want to give up the hunt all the
leaders also think that sauron is no
more and this was of course echoed in
the main trilogy when most thought that
he died though his fate was tied to the
one ring now we of course know that the
big battle is coming that was shown at
the start of the fellowship i'm guessing
that the series might even culminate
with a lead into that on the mountaintop
they managed to find refuge and if you
look at the stairs in the background
then you'll recognize them as being the
same one that sauron walked down during
the narration scene it's where the orcs
went after the fall of morgoth and
galadriel once more locates sauron's
symbol which acts as a trail whilst he's
lying low investigations quickly broken
up by what's been called a snow troll
and galadriel makes mincemeat over using
her brother's dagger to finish it off
anyway time for a joke what's gandalf's
favorite band the eagles thank you what
is tr what a terrific audience anyway
galadriel's company steps down and we
cut to ralvanian in the box this was a
small area east of merkwood that had the
great river anduin flowing through it we
initially see two walkers carrying giant
antlers on their back and though we
don't know these specific characters i
believe that they're normatic hunters
the main people that inhabit this land
are the hartfords who were the
predecessors to the hobbits these were
along with the stewarts and the fallow
hides who are all mentioned in the
concerning hobbits chapter living in the
woods i loved seeing how they all had
their little hideaways and we
predominantly follow eleanor browniefoot
whose nickname is nori invented for the
series we see she goes berry picking
with her sister and some kids but this
is interrupted by a warg now the design
for these has changed a lot with them
having hooves instead of paws and they
also look a lot like enthaldons she also
discovers a character known as the
stranger who falls from the sky but
we'll talk about it more later on in the
video nori very much represents the
hobbit that longs to leave their home
and though most of them tended to stick
to what they knew we had the offshoots
like bilbo who sought out adventure like
her due to their small size hobbit saw
safety in numbers which is an idea that
her mother hammers home into her head
cut to elrond who's relaxing by a tree
similar to how we were introduced to
frodo he's not yet the lord of rivendell
and whereas the movies would see him
holding the council of elrond here he's
not allowed to attend the one happening
that day this is taking place in linden
which is the capital of the high elves
this was actually where frodo sailed
from at the end of the return of the
king and it's also where galadriel
departs from come the end of this entry
we catch you looking over a mural
dedicated to this voyage which is
basically like when people move to
florida to retire the journey into the
west is described in a lot of tolkien's
work and most of the elves left to go
there at the end of the third age elves
are immortal and therefore they try and
preserve as much as possible whereas men
come and go so a lot of things change
with them the undying lands of valinor
were very much kept in a similar state
for eternity and it was placed beyond
the reach of mortal men because we'd we
just probably mess it up treat her like
a treat like a weekend away in my golov
now though not seen as an afterlife it's
very much a place of peace rest and
relaxation and it even held bilbo and
frodo with the wounds that they'd
sustained now collateral is told to go
there because she defy the king gilgalad
it's said he'll forgive her disobedience
as long as she sticks to the plan but
she of course ends up turning against
this now initially he doesn't believe
that sauron still exists but we know
from the overall story that he does
eventually end up heeding the warnings
he's pretty much the ignorant
high-ranking member of the government
stereotype character i think he's like
this because the elves lost so many that
he just wants to avoid any more conflict
not to spoil too much of what happens to
him but he's probably gonna have a
really interesting arc in the series now
that night we see an incredible firework
display echoing the one shown at
bilbao's birthday party at the start of
the fellowship gladreal very much feels
like she's letting her brother's memory
down by leaving and she even says that
she expected to rest amongst the carved
trees rather than traveling to the west
elrond at this point isn't the warrior
that he'd come to be and his arc is
likely building to the character
fighting in the big battle against
sauron next we jump across to the
southlands and join arundier who learns
he's being pulled out should have pulled
out like theo's dad but instead he
investigates a destroyed village as well
as something lurking beneath the surface
aaron there is an elf scout put in
charge of guarding over the area and we
can catch the face of an end on his
armor these pop up later on the episode
as the media crashes to earth and i hope
we get to see them at some point in the
series because they provide a lot of
entertainment [ __ ]
so but now he's got got sort of will
they want their relationship with theo's
mother bronwyn relationships like this
were of course forbidden but we've seen
a pop-up in the series even happening
with elrond's daughter arwyn and aragorn
there's a lot of talk about how crops
are dying and slowly the land is being
corrupted this is something similar to
what we saw with radagast the brown
whose home slowly started to become
shrouded in the darkness that was
poisoning the land the animals around
him became very ill and this is similar
to the cow whose milk turns to black
sludge the silmarillion talks about how
things like this first alerted the elves
to morgoth who had hid himself away and
it slowly started corrupting the
landscape there still exists an uneasy
alliance with the men because obviously
the elves are basically the police and
some of them still hate the humans for
siding with morgoth arendiere doesn't
want to leave his post and he's found a
home with them so move over theo say
hello to your new stepdad now theo has
possession of a black blade and we see
that it's been shattered this is similar
to aragorn's sword andreal which was
shattered during the battle with sauron
before it was reforged in rivendell now
what this sword is we don't know and i
actually spoke to mad at nude of the
rings about it and he broke down what's
likely the case i thought it might be
gotham but he said that amazon don't
actually own the rights to the children
of huron which they'd have to talk about
in order to properly introduce that
blade instead he thinks that it's
possibly a mogul blade as it reforms
instead of disappearing you might notice
it's visually similar to the way the
mogul blade disappears when aragorn
grabs it only here it happens in reverse
now due to having the symbol of sauron
on it it could have been formed at the
forge where galadriel found the mark and
it may pull from the unseen world this
is the wraith world where you pulled
into after being stabbed by one of the
blades and it's where frato starts to go
in the fellowship elsewhere elrond is a
side to lord keller brimbore who is said
to be one of the greatest elvin smiths
he and elrond end up traveling to
arakion which is where they see
theanor's hammer this helped to create
the cell morals and after morgoth stole
them he stared at the jewels for weeks
the book talks about how he saw so much
beauty and everything but this ate aware
at him and eventually it caused his
anger and rage to fester the idea of
items corrupting people of course
appears throughout lord of the rings and
it could also be linked to the sword he
talks about using elrond's health to
build a powerful forge and skip ahead 20
seconds if you don't want a minor
spoiler for the books
i'm just waiting for you to skip ahead
are you still here okay so keller
brimble actually ended up helping to
create the rings of power for the elves
so this forge is likely going to be what
makes them he also created the elf stone
for galadriel which was later given to
aragorn you've seen the original movies
mate
you know all about the rings but uh yeah
i just thought i'd put a spoiler warning
in case you didn't want things ruined
anyway quick quick they're coming back
and so i said you tried really hard on
this test timmy but you shall not pass
hey ravel off now the episode ends with
a stranger crash landing on earth and
that takes us into theory time
though the main theories surrounding
this guy tend to be that he's gandalf i
don't think that's the case wizards
don't tend to age and they came from the
sea instead of the sky gandalf also
didn't emerge until the third age and
though they're not sticking completely
to the cannon i think it would just
cause too much controversy to have him
drop in this way however he is
potentially a wizard and he might be a
blue one who helped to contest the will
of sauron now if we're going full tin
foil hat here then it might even be
sauron masquerading as a wizard in order
to trick the elves when meteor man crash
lands he burns an eye shape into the
floor and the fire also goes back into
him he also controls the fireflies later
on and sauron's eye itself was of course
made of a burning fire and we see his
leaves full with his arrival and this is
corrupted with the black goo that's
synonymous with the character rising up
sauron does need to appear at some point
in order to build towards the big battle
at the end of the second age and so far
the episodes don't really have a villain
well well outside of maybe theo i guess
but he's not that bad so it would be
good to get an antagonist appearing as a
friend the books did say that sauron
came from the shadows but they could be
changing his return into a celestial
event and this could also be the most
obvious thing and it may be the creative
team tricking us into thinking it's him
so they can pull a wool over our eyes
this could even be ilovator who could be
returning once more in order to
transition everyone from the second age
into the third nori does believe it's a
positive thing and that she was meant to
find him so i'm actually leaning more
towards it being a wizard out of the
possible theories he ends up shouting
which rocks the environment and this is
similar to what we saw saruman doing in
order to control the weather he also
accidentally snaps largo's ankle through
using a branch which is similar to a
wonderous staff now the firefly thing
could be similar to how gandalf speaks
to insects and if you cast your mind
back to the fellowship he actually
reached out to the eagles by speaking to
one that then passed on the message he
wants to find a certain constellation of
stars and in the end nori's gonna help
him get to it either way the stranger
seems to be causing a lot of death and
destruction so no one knows whether he's
good or bad yet let me know your
thoughts below on what you think and
i'll probably steal them and put them in
the next video but at the moment that's
in dude
now as the meteor comes down we see
aaron here and bronwyn holding hands and
also get galadriel's choice represented
by her brother's blade and her elf kin
trying to pull her in as the meteor
crashes down she jumps into the open
waters and that takes us into episode 2.
she ends up coming across a shipwreck
crew and she gets attacked by a giant
worm which i'm still calling a fish
dragon i absolutely love the way they
shoot the scene when she tries to swim
away from it and seeing the camera go
above and below the surface really adds
to the intensity of the attack in the
end all that's left are her and hal
brand who's a new character that's being
created for the show there are theories
that he might end up becoming the witch
king as that character's true identity
is still unknown if that's the case then
i think it negates the sauron twist with
the stranger as it would be stupid to
have two people turn out to be some of
the big bads now we discover that he and
the others were chased from their home
by orcs which eventually confirms to
galadriel that sauron is still working
away he says that the enemy is in the
southlands making me think that their
story is going to tie in with irandir
and bronwyn's very soon i love the way
that there's this horror feeling to the
entire situation at sea and this is
mirrored in the orc that attacks theo
and bronwyn it's really nice how it
calls back to horror moments in jaws and
slasher films in general leading to two
great scenes in episode two now in what
a more calm scene we watches alron and
calibrimbo gothic has a doom you might
recognize this from the main trilogy and
it's where the fellowship ended up
facing off against the balrog now the
main gates to the mines of moria had the
watcher in the water residing in the
lake outside of it here we can see the
stones and water that surrounds it but
it doesn't look deep enough to
eventually house the squid therefore i'm
guessing that this is an alternative
entrance and that's why the doorway can
be seen in the light love how they have
a bouncer on it i got a lot of vibes of
jabba's palace and some of the
nightclubs that i visit with ryan airy
just don't tell a wife now he challenges
jiren to a forfeit and he's eventually
allowed inside i believe this is
happening at the point where the dwarves
have only recently found mithril which
was used to create extremely durable
armor at the end of the entry during
talks to his father about whether
alright knows their secret or not and we
get a sort of pulp fiction scene where
they open up a chest we don't see what's
inside of it but the glow emanating from
it makes me think that it could be that
however they may have also unearthed the
silmaril and if they're playing fast and
loose with a cannon then that would make
sense for the overall plot now going
back to the myth role we saw his bilbo
and pradao had his [ __ ] made out of this
and it's likely that the mineral will be
discovered in the series that's if it
hasn't been already and we meet during
the ford's father during the third and
the rest of his family whose birthday
parties probably aren't worth going to
either now jiren iv was actually
believed to be during the first
reincarnated as he acted exactly the
same as him and the pair looked
identical at this point he's a prince
with his father still being the king
hence why he ends up handing gilgalad's
proposal over to him rather than making
a decision himself we see the contest
involved smashing rocks like their like
buttons and gimli tried a similar tactic
when he attempted to smash the ring at
the council of elrond elrond takes the l
on and he ends up being outcast but this
gives him a private audience with durian
which is where the pair meant their
friendship elves and dwarves came to
dislike each other by the third age but
here they have a friendship though most
of the elves are like lol you'll be dead
soon la mao this is given lip service by
jiren saying that he's been gone 20
years and elrond says has it been only
20 you bloody arrogant [ __ ] now due to
the way that elves view time in
comparison to the dwarves a lot of
friendship sprayed and you get so much
subtext from just this one line so
anyway elron concedes and jiren escorts
him out which is when the pair slowly
mend their friendship after he stays for
dinner here we meet diese and jiren's
kids and we see that there also exists a
tree within their home this is actually
a sapling from linden and though it was
thought it wouldn't grow on the mountain
the love between the pair has brought it
to fruition aaron dear does a little
digging where the enemy has done a
little digging and we get a scene where
he crawls through the tunnels that
reminded me a lot of the event scene
from alien where he's taken to we don't
know but sarah liked to torture those he
captured which is a similar situation to
what happened with galadriel's brother
theo and bronn get up close and personal
with the orc and after she confirms the
kill the villagers decide to head off to
the alvin tower theo takes a sword with
him that draws blood towards it and this
starts to rebuild the blade showing how
the darkness will follow them wherever
they flee the episode ends with
collateral and hal bran surviving a
storm and after the ladder saves her
life they start to form a bond now where
they're going was shown potentially in
the latest trailer you don't want any
future spoilers then turn off now and
huge thank you for checking out the
video really appreciate you sitting up
until this point and hopefully i see you
back next week you take care of yourself
now where they're likely heading is
numino which we know is gonna be a big
focus in the series we have seen shots
in the most recent trailer and these
contain boats sailing towards the city
they have similar sales to what we see
here and we also see hal brand at what
appears to be a port numenor is likely
gonna become a big location in the entry
and the fall of it is one of the major
moments in the lord of the rings law and
we also have shots where wargs approach
the stranger i'm guessing that this will
bring the one from episode one full
circle as we haven't had any resolution
from that in these two entries you can
actually see nori hiding away in the
tree behind him so it's clear that the
pair head off into the forest anyway
those are the main things that i wanted
to talk about that i think will happen
next time and as with my thoughts on the
episodes i did enjoy them even though i
thought there was some dips pacing wise
depending on who we were following a
full disclosure i have worked with
amazon before and i do get early access
to the shows i thought i'd drop that
before my full review so you kind of
know the extent of my relationship with
him and you can judge for yourself
whether i'm a paid shill that rides in
the shillenium falcon now i know there's
a lot of controversy around the series
and i tried to go into this judging it
off its own merit rather than the
conversation surrounding it and how i am
with amazon so all that out the way what
did i think well i absolutely loved the
first 15 minutes of episode 1 and i
thought that they did a great job of
recapturing the feeling of peter
jackson's films whilst also going off in
their own direction the prologue was
brilliant and you can definitely see why
this is the most expensive show of all
time there's a cinematic feeling to the
entire thing and watching galadriel and
her company scaling the mountains
completely blew me away however i did
think the mid part of that episode
namely this stuff with aaron dear kind
of fell a bit flat and it took a while
to get going i'm kind of in two minds
about the first episode and after seeing
them both twice i feel that they should
have just released the first due to the
cliffhanger that it had at the end now
the second episode didn't have the
bigger moments that the first one did
but do you think that overall it was
more consistent the wrath scenes were
all great and moments like this are
rarely shown in tv shows due to how
complicated they are to film i also love
the horror elements of the orcs and
there was a mystery involving certain
characters i feel like morphic clock is
really carrying the show with her
delivering a performance that has a lot
of rage pain and emotion to it she's the
standout for me which is then followed
by elrond who i think is also doing a
stellar job too my man who played jiren
was great as well i think there is a lot
to like here and lots of interesting
characters i probably prefer the first
two episodes of house of the dragon over
this i still think there's a lot to like
here and i hope that people go into the
series with an open mind because it has
so much potential the scale and scope of
it is like nothing we've seen on tv
before and though it started off slow i
think there are a number of ways that
they can take it i think now that we've
got the character introductions and
world building out the way that they can
just hit the ground running next week
and i am excited to see what happens now
i'd love to hear your thoughts if you
agree disagree whatever i'm guessing
there's going to be a lot of opinions on
the series so make sure you comment
below and let me know we are in a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of top gun maverick on the
15th of september and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episodes
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want to be able to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of house of the dragon which
will be linked on screen right now we go
over all the internets of episode 2 talk
about how it connects to the books and
also just have a great time going
through it bit by bit over analyzing it
is my my hobby now if not thanks for
sticking to the video hope to see in the
next one take care peace